a guy who did beat the Patriots oh I was
part of the Pittsburgh Steelers effort
juju Smith's juicer is gonna stop by but
I turned to my left in our great
cavalcade of guests has now brought
Christian McCaffrey into our mitts here
on the Rich Eisen show that's an
applause line for you folks from the
Carolina Panthers and courtesy of USAA
the official NFL salute the service
partner good to see you Christian
McCaffrey good to see appreciate ya what
was the difference for you season two to
season one it looked like you were a
little bit more in the flow of things
this year to say the least yeah I would
say a lot slowed down for me I'll tell
you what was tough was my rookie year
going into my rookie year because of the
the rule where you can't participate in
any team activities until your school
technically graduates was tough so I got
to experience the benefit of going
through OTAs and going through different
mini camps whereas my rookie I didn't
and I tell you what that had a huge
impact that was one of the things where
I just I got more comfortable I got
bigger
I got faster I got stronger and overall
I just felt better felt you know that
everything kind of slowed down for me
yeah it looked it looked like they were
just gonna ride Christian McCaffrey
every single game it seemed like you
were the focus would that be an accurate
assessment of the game plan well yeah I
mean I would say I don't I wouldn't say
you know going into the game we were we
were planning on this or that I think
some of the games ended up being that
way I think some some also didn't and
some other guys stepped up and you know
we have such a talented team that the
ball can really go anywhere and you know
when we're healthy when our guys are
feeling good you know we got a great
team it's tough to win in the NFL you
saw that with us late in the stretch yes
multiple games were losing by six or
under and you know despite all that
we're one game away from from being in
the playoffs oh definitely a frustrating
second half of the season but knowing
that we got the guys we got the coaches
and we overall haven't have a great
attitude in the locker room and
something to look forward to in the
future
well it's awesome to see that you think
that you have a great attitudes that you
skipped your bowl game and anybody who
does that has a horrible attitude tare
no chance of doing anything in the NFL
like to say most receptions by running
back in a single season as you have
sowed your your breaking that motivation
yeah appreciate it yeah you'd have
thought I committed a crime
when I did it now everybody's
everybody's doing it getting applauded
for it it's just the norm now so you
were the George Washington of this you
were the first across that Delaware so
what do you think of when you hear
coaches say well this kids skipping a
bowl game on and I don't think that
that's gonna really play very well on
the next level you don't want to take a
kid who skipped a bowl game like you
just did yeah I mean years ago I would
say each and every decision and any time
you look at a situation where a player's
given a moment you have to look at it
from from their decision I made my
decision I mean whether or not it's
right for anyone else is up to them and
I'm in my decision and I like to think
it worked out and you know I know what
my attitude was and I know I and I my
reasons and you know some guys have
their reasons it might be different from
mine but I would say at the end of the
day you got to look yourself in the
mirror and be able to tell yourself that
you made the best decision for yourself
and for your future and if you can do
that then then it's the right decision
what did David Shaw say we had some
tough conversations I think you know in
the long run coach Shaw's being great
been very supportive of me nor still
keep in touch with him today you know
definitely it was a tough decision it's
tough for me it's the hardest decision
I've ever had to make
I went back and forth of it you know I
will always you know I don't say regret
it but I will always miss that
opportunity and I'll always be mad at
myself for that moment but but in the
once again in the long run and seeing
how it all played out I can't say I made
the wrong decision and that could be
true for some people I took I took a
risk and happy I did but but as far as
coach Shaw goes man we did have some
tough conversations and I'm happy that
we've remained close yeah I mean he
talks very well of you by the way off
camera just so you know when he sits
next to me on the draft set last couple
of years obviously when you were up for
being drafted you want up being a top 10
pick that guy if I'm an owner in the NFL
I send him a check and if I need a new
head coach I send him a check and say
right you're right you're a mountain at
David I want you to be my head coach he
just doesn't seem to want to do that do
you think he
who would ever do something like that
come into the NFL man I have no idea but
I think if he ever did he'd be great
he's he's unbelievable obviously he's an
unbelievable lead or mentor he's an
unbelievable person but you look at his
resume coaching and it's pretty
remarkable to see what he's done and you
know Stanford's a tough school to
recruit to and and to have the success
he's had with you know with the guys
that we have has been been awesome you
know every year we're racking up the top
players in the nation somehow he gets
him to go there and it's it's been
really fun to see and and and I was just
very lucky I got to be a part of this
his uh his run there and your brother
Dylan plays for his predecessor it's
direct yeah now Michigan right I mean he
burst against Penn State and then went
away is he I hope so man I you know I
really hope so I think he's uh you know
honest you know sometimes I have to be
an honest evaluator yes and so I look at
it unbiased and-and-and man he's got
he's got everything I would want in a
quarterback so I think he's got an
unbelievably bright future ahead of him
and I can't can't wait to see what he
does do we know what the new offensive
coordinator thinks of them do you have
you I'm trying to get I gotta hop on the
phone of them but okay you know if I was
an OC I would play him I mean he is he
faster than you I'll tell you what he's
the fastest mechanic if you were to tell
me before I think he had a long 75 yard
run against somebody who's I think it's
days I remember all of these things and
and if I if you were to tell me before
the game he's gonna run 175 yards out of
thought you're nuts but he's continued
to prove me wrong he's not faster than
me though okay but he is fast okay he is
fast all right when your dad was playing
was he faster than you see if you ask
anybody in our family who the fastest is
who's the best high school basketball
player any of these questions yes each
and every person will say themselves and
will go on forever it's gotten very
personal in our house I'm gonna I'm
gonna go ahead and continue sticking
with my answer okay with myself my older
brother has the 40 he's around the
fastest 40 out of all of us
so he went he wins the time for tea now
we didn't all run on the same clock the
circumstances weren't the same sure one
of these days we'll have to put a sign
will came up or a race or something to
make it even I don't think we have video
when your dad ran it good enough sander
definition I know from back in that day
seriously black and white Christian
McCaffrey here on the Rich Eisen show CJ
Anderson is in the Superbowl and he had
I guess what would you call it a cup of
coffee with your team this year how long
how often how long was he around your
team he was around four until I I mean I
forget when when we released him but
tell you what I mean he's got an
unbelievable attitude and it's been it's
been fun to see I was lucky to be able
to pick his brain a little bit and you
know obviously he's had success in this
league he's gone to Pro Bowls he's won
Super Bowl and being able to pick his
brain and see where that's kind of
coming from what was really cool for the
time we had and you know no one was
surprised when when you know he got
picked up and obviously see the impact
he's had no eye has been pretty pretty
fun to watch yeah it's been amazing to
see how how dynamic he has been with
early how do you see Super Bowl 53
playing out Christian McCaffrey
I hope they both lose I think you know
it's very tough to bet against team like
the Patriots and Tom Brady and but then
you look at LA with the firepower they
have all over the place so I just hope
it's a competitive game I'm gonna give
you the politically correct answer it's
not is not an acceptable answer but I
mean you know when you when you take a
look at it being a football guy that you
are a smart guy as you pointed out in a
very passive aggressive way that you
couldn't get to training camp in time
worth mini campus on because Stanford
was too busy no that's that's educating
their kids deep into the something NFL
role that's not a no no no but you
you're pointing all that out that's okay
I dropped out already I didn't go to
school I was just training so do you you
just point blank you think Patriots
because if Brady is that what you're
saying
once again and III mean out I'll say you
know it's hard to hard to bet against
Tom that's what I'll say okay um cams
shoulder what can you tell me about it
obviously it looks like he's getting it
tightened up a little bit you know how
how much do you think that affect your
offense throughout the season Christian
well I think you know obviously he was
playing through a lot I think there's a
lot of people who play through a lot and
I think that's League wide you know
you're not gonna find a team who's not
playing with some injuries here and
there but I can tell you this that he's
he's one of the toughest guys I've ever
played with in my life and he's willing
to risk everything for the team and I
know he's going to take every single
situation extremely seriously and we
have an unbelievable staff in Carolina
and so he's on the right path and he's I
hope hopefully he'll come back healthier
than ever you think see do you think
Olson is gonna play anymore he's one of
my favorite people yeah he's the best
I hope I hope he does man he's been an
unbelievable mentor obviously his play
speaks for himself over the past few
years and you know he always says he's
getting older and older but I don't want
to hear it cuz I know he still has it
and if he can stay healthy man he's a
heck of an impact on our team I need to
amend that to he's one of my favorite
people not named Ryan Khalil cuz Ryan
gets very sensitive if I don't mention
him like that's you know yeah very
sensitive guy like Luke Kuechly was a
guest on our show at the Super Bowl last
year and he got a Rich Eisen show jacket
that he wore and I got a text from Ryan
Khalil of that photograph saying where's
my job so that sounds about right don't
you think so I think I think Ryan
obviously offensive linemen don't get
enough credit but I think Ryan is a Hall
of Famer Hall of Fame person and I think
he was the biggest biggest leader slash
impact on our on our team as far as the
last two years up really are you saying
that cuz he's a sensitive guy you really
caught me well he's sensitive and he
would he would definitely text me after
if if I didn't say that but no but no
but I absolutely mean them and he's salt
of the earth I mean it doesn't get
better than this of good people on the
Panthers and you are one of them sir
thee
salutes a service partner of the
National Football League USAA and the
Wounded Warrior Project awarded a
military member a trip of a lifetime to
the Super Bowl right here is in and you
are guiding this military member yes
yeah it's been an absolute blast being
able to work with USA and Wounded
Warrior Project we sent sergeant
Summerson and his wife Shawna who's also
military gave them two tickets so it's
been a great week being able to partner
with them and do some things with them
and then at the end of the week I'll get
to meet them which will be a blast and
then some other military members as well
so that's been really cool and then
definitely made the trip worth it yeah
for sure growing up in Colorados you did
obviously that's a great military state
you know the state of Colorado you know
you know this is neat stuff that you're
bringing these these folks to the
Superbowl and I look forward to you
meeting them over the weekend last one
for you while you were i mean you've
talked about this before but never on
this show video of you of his 7 year old
okay running through mascots we have it
right here on the screen of course I
mean come on now this is is it an old
school that now this is a halftime of a
Broncos game halftime yeah I don't know
who the Broncos are playing this at like
that here you are running making she
moves right through all that great block
picked up a couple great blocks but
here's the best part about it here's the
best part
no I'd never celebrate just give the
ball to the ref run back to the sideline
that's what I was taught and then you
pull out the sharpie and sign the
football dude I think that was the last
time I celebrated I think that was the
last time so I got a lot of flack for
that one but mascots big game obviously
halftime of the Bronco game you know I
had to let loose a little bit so what
was the aftermath of that I was playing
up on my well my dad was in the locker
room at halftime so I don't I think he
might have retired by then but now I was
it I don't want to say it was planned
but our team had planned I was playing
on my brother's team so I was playing a
couple years up I was the young guy on
the team
I had to listen to what they told me to
do well how to be plan unless you always
had a sharpie yeah well I love them with
sharpies in my sock so look I look
forward to seeing this this fall see
Christian McCaffrey do that good to see
you man you say you have me that run
underscore CMC on Twitter so Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience